[موسيقى]
على بعد مسافه القصيره من القصر الرئاسي
تلوح في الافق هذه القبه كما تلوح قبه
الصخره في افق مدينه القدس من امام مقر
السفاره الفلسطينيه في العاصمه البرازيليه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في كل مكان الى هذه
الحلقه الخاصه من برنامج من واشنطن تاتيكم
هذا الاسبوع من العاصمه برازيليا بعد حمله
الانتخابيه حاميه الوطيس فاز لويس ايناسيو
لولادا سيلفا في الانتخابات البرازيليه
وعدد سيلفا الى الحكم للمره الثالثه خلفا
هذه المره للرئيس جائر بولسونارو الذي كان
قد وعد بنقل السفاره البرازيليه من تل
ابيب الى القدس
دون ان يتاتى ذلك في نهايه المطاف
خلال حفل تنصيبه في الاول من شهر يناير من
هذا العام قال الرئيس لويس سيناسيو لولادا
سيلفا في خطابه
ستقف بلادنا ثابته في دعمها للحقوق
الفلسطينيه وستعمل على استعاده حريه
واستقلال فلسطين داخل حدود 1967
ما هي محركات هذا الدعم وما هي ابعاده
وتعقيداته
البرازيل بلد مؤثر ففي عام 2010 لحقت
حكومات الارجنتين وتشيلي وفنزويلا ودول
اخرى في امريكا اللاتينيه لاحقت بحكومه
لولاد السلفا الثانيه في اعترافها هي ايضا
بدوله فلسطين
ولكن البرازيل تشهد كذلك هذه الايام
انقساما غير مسبوق فبول سونارو الذي لا
يزال يحظى بدعم واسع في البرازيل رغم
خسارته في الانتخابات الرئاسيه كان من
داعم اسرائيل وسار على درب الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب في دعمه لها
في البرازيل انجيليون دعموا بول سونارو
كما دعم نظرائهم الامريكيون دونالد ترامب
في البرازيل ايضا يهود برازيليون دعم
العديد منهم مواقف بولسونارو السياسيه من
اسرائيل رغم ان العديد منهم قد اختلفوا مع
ايضا في بعض القضايا الاجتماعيه
فكيف سيدير الرئيس لولادا سيلفا ملفا
فلسطين في هذا السياق البرازيلي المعقد
كنت قد سالت سيلسو اموريم السكرتيره الخاص
للرئاسه البرازيليه عن هذه القضايا وغيرها
في لقاء خاصه به برنامج من واشنطن في مقر
القصر الرئاسي هنا في برازيليا
سيد صلصه مريم شكرا جزيلا على تلبيه
الدعوه شكرا على استقبالنا في القصر
الرئاسي هنا في برازيليا اريد في البدايه
ان اسال عن اهميه الموقف الذي اعلنه
الرئيس دا سيلفا في خطاب تنصيب عن فلسطين
حسنا لست على درايه بتفاصيل تاريخ موقفنا
من هذا الامر ولكن بشكل عام موقف البرازيل
كان مدافعا عن الحقوق الفلسطينيه وعن
اقامه الدوله والرئيس لولا كان له سجل خاص
في هذا الاطار وحكومته كذلك فنحن نعترف
بفلسطين كدوله واعتقد ان البرازيل كانت من
اولى الدول في امريكا اللاتينيه اعترافا
بفلسطين ولان للبرازيل وزنها تبعتها دول
كثيره في الاعتراف بفلسطين من ضمنها
اوروغواي وباراغواي وتشيلي وكل هؤلاء حذوا
حضنا الرئيس لولا ايضا قام بزياره فلسطين
حتى يعين معاناه الشعب الفلسطيني بشكل
شخصي وقمت ايضا بزياره فلسطين خمس او ست
مرات تحت قيادته بالطبع
اعتقد انها قضيه مهمه من بقايا الاستعمار
ان صح التعبير ومن المهم ان يكون موقفنا
واضحا من هذا
يعني هل
جذور الموقف البرازيلي او موقف الرئيس
لولا في قضيه فلسطين هل منبعه
ميولاته الايديولوجيه كشخص ينتمي الى
اليسار ام
منبعوا هذا الموقف هو انه في جاليات عربيه
كبيره في البرازيل ما هو المنبع على وجه
التحديد لموقف الرئيس ذا سيلفا في موضوع
فلسطين
اولا اعتقد انه من الصواب ان ندعم فلسطين
ولكن دعني اقول لك انه فيما يتعلق بالرئيس
لولا ربما يكون لديه نوع من التعاطف مع
المقموعين لانه ياتي من طبقه فقيره في
البرازيل فهو من الجزء الفقير شمال شرقي
البلاد وعمل في وظيفه بسيطه كعامل معالم
تولى قياده احدى النقابات لذلك لديه شعور
خاص تجاه هؤلاءك المقموعين وربما كان
لوجود الكثير من من لهم اصول عربيه في
البرازيل تاثير ولكن الحقيقه ان هؤلاء
ليسوا ناشطين بالمعنى الحرفي بالطبع
سيفضلون دعم ابنائي عمومتهم ولكن طالما
كان لدينا في المجتمع البرازيلي مجتمع
عربي موجودا لسنوات طويله ولم يكن الرئيس
لولا اول الداعمين لفلسطين بالطبع ولكنه
قام باول زياره الى فلسطين واقدم على فتح
السفاره الفلسطينيه هنا وخلال حكومته
تشرفت بالانخراط في هذا الامر وبالطبع اهم
امر حدث كان الاعتراف بدوله فلسطين ليعيش
الفلسطينيون بامان في دوله ذات اقتصاد
قابل للحياه وايضا كان الرئيس لولا من
اكبر المدافعين عن السلام وهو يؤمن ان
السلام لا يمكن ان يتحقق بالقمع ولهذا
ينبغي ان يتمتع الناس بالحريه وبالقدره
على ممارسه النشاط الاقتصادي لقد كنت هناك
عده مرات وعاينت الصعوبات التي يعايشها
الشعب الفلسطيني في الحقيقه الوضع صادم
لانك هناك ترى الطرق السريعه والفلسطينيون
ينبغي عليهم الالتفاف حولها واعتقد ان تلك
هي القضايا التي شجعته على دعم القضيه
وبالطبع لديه اهتمام خاص بالعالم العربي
ايضا ولا ازال اذكر عندما زارنا احد الق
الفلسطينيين خلال زياره لنا الى مصر
اشرت قبل قليل الى ان هناك ملايين من
البرازيليين من اصول عربيه في البرازيل
الملايين من البرازيليين كذلك من اليهود
وبالتالي كيف تعتقد ان الرئيس لولا يوازن
بين
الوضع الداخلي في ظل وجود ملايين من
اليهود البرازيليين
وما تقوم به الحكومه الاسرائيليه حاليا في
الوضع الراهن في الملف الفلسطيني
دعني اقول ان الرئيس لولا داعم جدا
لفلسطين بالطبع لكنه ليس مناويا لاسرائيل
فقد زار اسرائيل والحقيقه انه كان اول من
يزور اسرائيل من الرؤساء البرازيليين
لدينا علاقات ممتازه وهو يحترم ذكرى ضحايا
الهولوكوست اذا ليس هناك تناقض في الامر
فنحن نشجع السلام وحل الدولتين اللتين
تعيشان جنبا الى جنب ونعلم ان هذا امر صعب
للغايه ولكن هذا ما ينبغي ان نعمل من اجله
اذا لا ارى تناقضا وبالطبع نحن فقط ضد
الاحتلال غير المشروع للاراضي الفلسطينيه
وبشده ولا نوافق عليه وبالفعل اصدر وزير
الخارجيه منذ فتره بيانا يدين الوضع الذي
اسفر عن سقوط القتلى في فلسطين والضفه
الغربيه لكن لا ارى تناقضا بين ان نكون
اصدقاء وربما لا يعجب نا تصرف حكومه ما
ولكن لا يوجد تناقض بين صداقتنا للشعب
الفلسطيني وللشعب الاسرائيلي وكثير منهم
يرغب في السلام زرت اسرائيل عده مرات
واعرفوا اناسا يريدون علاقات سلميه ومن
ضمنهم المسؤولون الحكوميون الذين شاركوا
في المفاوضات ونحن نحاول دعمه
انما عمليا
بطبيعه الحال هناك علاقات عمليه
استثمارات
اتفاقيات تجاريه
اتفاقيات امنيه بين البرازيل واسرائيل
وفي نفس الوقت البرازيل تحاول ان تكون لها
علاقات مع الاسرائيليين ومع الفلسطينيين
عمليا كيف يمكن للبرازيل ان تؤثر في الوضع
الحالي بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين في
مرحله ما بعد التنديد مثلا بالمواقب
الاسرائيليه
ليس هذا بالامر السهل لا للبرازيل بل
للعالم اجمع كيف نتعامل مع الامر وكما قال
الرئيس لولا امام الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده انهم اقاموا دوله اسرائيل ولم يكن
بمقدورهم اقامه او الاعتراف الكامل بدوله
فلسطين وهذا يتطلب الكثير وانا اتفق معك
انه يتطلب اكثر من الادانه او التعبير عن
الصداقه ونؤمن ان الامر يتطلب التفاوض
يتطلب الرغبه في التعايش السلمي ولم يكن
هناك وقت حتى خلال رئاسه لولا السابقه فقد
توالت المشكلات ولكن ظللنا ان الحل ممكن
وخلال ذلك الوقت قمت بزياره القاده
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين والمفاوضين
بتعليمات من الرئيس لولا لان الامل راودنا
ان تصميم خارطه الطريق سيساعد وحضرنا
المؤتمر الشهير في مدينه النابلس
الامريكيه حيث الامور ممكنه وقمنا بادانه
كل ما من شانه جعل الامور اكثر صعوبه وهذا
ما امكننا عمله لان هذه المساله من اكثر
الامور تعقيدا على مستوى العالم ولا يوجد
حل سحري لها بل يكمن الحل في اتخاذ قرارات
متواليه للتوصل الى حل سلمي والرئيس لولا
مصمم على مواصله العمل من اجل السلام وهو
امر يزداد صعوبه حول العالم حاليا ولكن
على ايه حال سنعمل على ايجاد السلام في
الشرق الاوسط وخاصه بين فلسطين واسرائيل
الامر ليس بسيطا ويتطلب عوامل كثيره ولكن
ينبغي علينا ان نتحدث ونتفاوض وبمجرد بدء
التفاوض يتغير وضع الامور التي تبدو
مستحيله الى وضع اكثر قابليه للحل ولكن
بالطبع يتطلب هذا اراده سياسيه وتفاهما
اننا يجب ان نعمل سويا الى ان ندمر
معنويات الطرف الاخر هذه هي الطريقه وهذا
ليس امرا بسيطا ولكن هذه هي الطريقه
لاحلال السلام يعني الرئيس السابق جعير
وثق العلاقات البرازيليه مع اسرائيل كان
في وقت من الاوقات قد قال انه سينقل
السفاره البرازيليه من تل ابيب الى القدس
لم يحصل ذلك في نهايه المطاف انما ما حجم
التوازن او اعاده التوازن الذي يتعين على
حكومه الرئيس لولا الان القيام به في
الوضع بين اسرائيل والفلسطينيين
اولا هناك توجهنا ازاء القرارات ذات
الصلاه
ومساله اعاده احياء علاقاتنا مع الشعب
الفلسطيني لا اعلم بالضبط متى يمكن لاي
منا او لوزير خارجيتنا القيام بزياره او
استقبال مسؤولين هنا في البرازيل الامر
مختلف تماما وما اقصده هو ان لدي اصدقاء
في اسرائيل واصدقاء كثر هنا في البرازيل
ومن المهم للغايه ان نعلم ان اليهود
التقدميين في البرازيل الذين يعارضون بناء
جدار الفصل ومساله الفصل والهيمنه هي كانت
تعبير الذي تستخدمه والتدخل في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه هناك كثير من اليهود الذين
اعرفهم وبالطبع الرئيس السابق بولسونارو
خالف التقاليد البرازيليه ليس فقط خالفها
فيما يتعلق بالرئيس لولا ولكنه خالف كل
الامور التي كانت ق ائمه في السابق ولن
يحدث هذا بالتاكيد خلال عهدنا ولدينا ايضا
امور اخرى تشغلنا مثل اليمين المتطرف وما
يحدث في العالم وهذا ينبغي ان يؤخذ في
الحسبان عندما ننظر الى امر منطقه الشرق
الاوسط
يعني في ظل هذا الكلام بالنسبه للجانب
الفلسطيني يعني كيف تعتقد انه يمكن تمكين
الجانب الفلسطيني من التعويل على المواقف
البرازيليه في المستقبل بصرف النظر عن من
يتولى الرئاسه في البرازيل ام انك تعتقد
ان هذا طبع الديمقراطيه الحكومه تتغير
ومعها تتغير المواقف
ونفس لا يمكننا بطبيعه الحال تقديم ضمان
شامل ولكن اذا لاحظت الخط الذي اتبعناه
على مدى 50 عاما ستجد انه متسق حتى خلال
الحكم العسكري هنا في البرازيل تم القبول
بفتح مكتب منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه اذا
بولسونارو هو الذي غير المسار وليس الرئيس
والرئيس لولا قدم اكثر من غيره بالطبل
وتطوعت البرازيل بلاعب دوري في المفاوضات
اذا كانت هناك حاجه وهناك اطراف اتصلت
بالبرازيل بالفعل كما ذكرت لك حضورنا في
مؤتمر انابلس وهذا كان امرا غير مسبوق
ولكن اعتقد ان الرئيس السابق بولسونارو
غرد خارج السياق فيما يخص خط البرازيل
واعتقد ان تكويننا وطريقه تصرفنا تاريخيا
لا تسمح بعوده بولسنر ربما يحدث هذا انا
لا اعلم او ربما يعود دون الترامب في
الولايات المتحده او يصل اليمين المتطرف
الى السلطه في مكان ما لا اعلم ولكن من
المهم لنا ان ننتبه جيدا الى اليمين
المتطرف لا اقصد القول ان كل حكومات
اسرائيل تنتمي الى اليمين المتطرف ولكن
اليمين المتطرفه في البرازيل يميل الى
التماهي مع مثيره في اسرائيل او الى قوى
بعينها في اسرائيل واعتقد ان هذا وما
ينبغي ان نتجنبه اعرف كثيرا من اليساريين
من اصحاب الراي والفكر او الموالين
للديمقراطيه في اسرائيل وهم اناس رائعون
ويعملون من اجل السلام وهؤلاء هم من ينبغي
الحديث اليهم او الى الاشخاص العمليين
ربما يكون لديهم مواقف متطلبه ولكنهم
عمليون ويجب ان اقول انني عندما شغلت منصب
وزير الخارجيه سابقا هنا في البرازيل
تحدثت الى رئيس الوزراء ووزير الخارجيه في
اسرائيل ولا اقول انهم كانوا لينين مع
فلسطين ولكنهم كانوا عمليين احتاجوا الى
السلام من اجل فائدتهم ومصلحتهم
هؤلاء هم من يجب التفاوض معهم واتمنى ان
يكون لديهم نفوذ في اسرائيل
عندما اعترفت البرازيل بدوله فلسطين قبل
حوالي عشر سنوات
او اكثر
تبعتها دول اخرى في امريكا اللاتينيه
الارجنتين شيلي الى غير ذلك
هذه الدول اليوم او العديد منها تحكمها
حكومات يساريه كما هو الوضع في البرازيل
هل يمكن ان يساعد ذلك في التعامل مع
القضيه الفلسطينيه ام انما حصل ام ان عالم
قد تغير الان في عام 2023
اعتقد انه يمكننا العمل مع تلك الدول وحتى
التعبير عن اصواتهم اتذكر عندما تحدث رئيس
بيرو السابق هوجيكا مع الرئيس لولا بعد
حدث معين يمس الشرق الاوسط ولا يتعلق
بفلسطين تحديدا لكنه قال ان لدى موقفي
البلدين نوعا من التناسق بالطبع المواقف
تتغير من الى اخرى ولكن اعتقد ان الاوضاع
تتطابق ولكن يجب ان تتوفر ظروف اقليميه
وجيو السياسيه تلائم ذلك اعني انه في
العقد الاول من القرن الجاري كان هناك
جهود اكثر لتحقيق السلام في العالم عما هو
عليه الوضع الان انظر الى ما يحدث حاليا
بين اوكرانيا وروسيا وغيرها اعتقد ان
الامر اصبح اكثر صعوبه الان ولكنه ليس
مستحيلا وهو يعتمد على اراده الشعوب وفي
يوم ما يتعين على الجميع ان يتفهموا ان
مساله الحرب والهيمنه والقمع لن تؤدي الى
نتائج طيبه وانها ستخلف شعورا بالخوف وكما
تعلم ان الجدار امر سيء للفلسطينيين ولكنه
بشكل او باخر امر سيء للاسرائيليين ايضا
لانهم لا يمكنهم التنقل لذا اعتقد ان هذا
الشعور يجب ان يؤخذ فيلات وكما قلت رايت
خلال العقد الاول من هذه الالفيه اشخاصا
لا ينتمون الى اليسار بالضروره
وكانوا اعضاء في حكومه اسرائيل ولكنهم
كانوا يريدون التفاوض ولم يكن التفاوض
معهم هينا وبدا لي ان الامر لن يكون سهلا
وهذا ما ينبغي العوده اليه وبالطبع الضغط
من القوه الكبرى امر هام في المنطقه
وخارجها من اجل ان ينخرط الجميع في العمل
من اجل السلام لان هذا هو السبيل الوحيد
لجعل السلام قويا اذا تحكمت في الاخرين
باستخدام القوه سياتي اليوم الذي يثورون
عليك فيه ولذا اعتقد ان الظروف اكثر صعوبه
حاليا ولكن هذا ليس عائقا ويمكننا العمل
لايجاد السلام
نهايه في هذا الموضوع الرئيس لولا يستعد
للذهاب الى واشنطن سترافقه انت كما علمت
هل المباحثات مع اداره الرئيس بايدن
يمكن ان تشمل باي شكل من الاشكال
منطقه الشرق الاوسط فلسطين واسرائيل ام ان
هذه المباحثات ستنصب حصريا على العلاقات
الثنائيه بين البرازيل والولايات المتحده
خصوصا في ظل احداث الثامن من يناير وتلك
الله
لم تقتصر المحادثات فقط على العلاقات
الثنائيه بين البرازيل وامريكا ستكون
بالطبع جزءا من اللقاء ولكن ايضا مساله
الديمقراطيه وكيفيه دعمها ستكونان بالطبع
ضمن مواضيع الاجتماع
سيتناول النقاش القضايا الدوليه والشرق
الاوسط بالطبع جزء من ذلك وايضا
اوروبا وروسيا ربما يطغى هذا على بعض
القضايا ولكن هذا سبب اضافي لاهميه احلال
السلام هناك حتى يمكن ان توجه الجهود نحو
قضايا اخرى اعتقد ان من الوارد جدا مثل ما
حدث في الماضي وتحدث الرئيس لولا وتحدثت
انا ايضا الى مسؤولين مثل كوندوليساريس او
لمسؤولين اخرين عن الشرق الاوسط وكما تحدث
الرئيس لولا في السابق الى الرئيس بوش او
رئيس اوباما عن الشرق الاوسط لهذا لن
استبعد الحديث عن الشرق الاوسط لان
السلامه سيكون جزءا رئيسيا من المحادثات
وكيف يمكن الحديث عن السلام دون ذكر الشرق
الاوسط ومعانات الفلسطينيين بشكل او باخر
لا يمكنني ان اقول ان هذا الامر سيكون
موضوعا قائما بذاته ولكنه سيكون جزءا من
التفكير بشان السلام شكرا جزيلا
كان ذلك سيلسو اموريم السكرتيره الخاص
للرئاسه البرازيليه في لقاء حصري مع
برنامج من واشنطن بوعيدا اللقاء زار
الرئيس دا سيلفا واشنطن والتقى بالرئيس
بايدن وناقش عده قضايا كان من بينها ملف
الشرق الاوسط الرئيس البرازيلي ذا سيلفا
زارا واشنطن استجابه لدعوه كان قد تلقاها
من الرئيس جو بايدن
انا مقتنع اننا نعيش في حقبه مختلفه لقد
عادت البرازيل الى المسرح العالمي وهي
تطوع قوتها الدبلوماسيه واحترامها الذي
اكتسبت حتى تطلع الشعوب والدول الاخرى
بالمهمات التي ينبغي علينا القيام بها من
اجل الانسانيه
كنت في وقت سابق قد التقيت كذلك بالسفير
الفلسطيني لدى البرازيل ابراهيم الزبن في
مقر السفر الفلسطينيه من ضمن القضايا التي
اثرتها معه في هذا اللقاء جماليات ورسائل
الشكل الهندسي للسفاره
سلسفير بدايه شكرا جزيلا على استقبالنا في
السفاره الفلسطينيه شكرا على هذه المقابله
تحت قبه السفاره
عطفا عليه اريد ان اسالك يعني هذا الشكل
الهندسي للسفاره الفلسطينيه في برازيليا
بطبيعه الحال يستحضر قبه الصخره في بلدك
البرازيل يعني ما هي رمزيه
هذا الهيكل الذي يستذكر قبه الصخره في قلب
العاصمه البرازيليه
اول شيء شكرا على زيارتكم واهلا وسهلا
فيكم في سفاره فلسطين
فلسطين موجوده في برازيليا وكان هذا هو
التصور
القياده الفلسطينيه لما قررنا نبني اول
سفاره
لنا في امريكا في الامريكتين عمليا
في قانون او عرف في
البرازيليا العاصمه انه يستحسن من
السفارات عندما تريد ان تبني سفاره انها
تحضر شيء من بلدها
والهدف طبعا انه ابن برازيليا او زائر
برازيليا يزور العالم من خلال زيارته لهذه
السفرات فكانت هذه الفكره والله يرحمه
المهندس ابراهيم عياش هو اللي صمم هذا
المبنى
وبدانا احنا في البناء عمليا عام 2013
فبالتالي فلسطين موجوده من خلال
مجسم قبه الصخره في برازيليا السيد سفير
لاحظنا في
السفاره الفلسطينيه صور
لمراسله الجزيره شيرين ابو عقله واريد ان
استغل هذه الفرصه لاسالك كيف
استقبل البرازيليون نبا مقتل شيرين ابو
عقله عندما حصل مقتل شيرين كانت صدمه صدمه
مش للصحفيين كان الصدمه لكل العالم عمليا
هذا الاغتيال البشع للصحافه ولا الكلمه
الحره
واحنا
يعني قمنا بعمل
فتحنا كتاب التعزيه
وام العديد من الشخصيات والسفارات
لتوقيع لتوقيع هذا هذا الكتاب كتاب
التعزيه هذه الصدمه كانت لنا جميعا
فقط للجزيره الله يرحمها وهي مثل يحتذى
فيه كصحفيه وكمناضله عن الكلمه الحره الان
السيد سفير عوده لما تفضلت به في جوابك
الاول عن العلاقه بين الفلسطينيين
والبرازيل يعني كيف تسير الامور
سواء مع
الجهات الرسميه او مع الشعب في البرازيل
بالنسبه للقضيه الفلسطينيه حتى الان
الحقيقه انه قضيه فلسطين حاضره
في البرازيل منذ عقود
فلسطين موجوده منذ زياره
[موسيقى]
الثاني اللي هو امبراطور البرازيل في
القرن التاسع عشر لفلسطين هذه زياره اللي
فتحت الباب امام هجره العديد مش بس من
الفلسطينيين ايضا من العرب قضيه فلسطين هي
قضيه ضمير وبالتالي هي موجوده عند هذا
الشعب الودود هذا الشعب الطيب
واحنا سعيدين جدا
كما انه العالم العربي والاسلامي والعام
بشكل عام سعيدين بعوده البرازيل الى
مكانها الطبيعي بعد استلام الرئيس لولا
السلطه واستلام
وعودته بعد الانتخابات الاخيره هذا يعني
بعزز املنا بدور البرازيه للايجابي
التاريخي
البرازيل طول عمرها ومنذ عام 47 حاضره في
القضيه الفلسطينيه
صوتت وتصوت دائما
لصالح الحق احنا سعيدين بعوده البرازيل
للمسار التقليدي اعلى انا طول عمرها
البرازيل بتشارك في الدفاع عن القانون
الدولي
وبالتالي بتدافع عن قضيه فلسطين عن حق
فلسطين باقامه دولتها المستقله وعاصمتها
القدس
مستمرين بهذا الدعم واحنا يعني عندما
التقى معالي الوزير الدكتور رياض المالكي
في معالي الوزير مارو فييرا
حتى قبل ان يتسلم
مهامك وزير يوم وعهد 31 ديسمبر اكد له قال
البرازيل اعتبارا من غد ستعود الى وضح
الطبيعي في الدفاع عن القانون الدولي
والقانون الدولي الانساني وعن حق الشعب
الفلسطيني في اقامه المستقله احنا سعيدين
وبنامل انه البرازيل فعلا
تعود الى سابق عادها وبدات تعود الى سابق
عاده في التصويت لصالح فلسطين في المحافل
الدوليه البرازيل لها دور مهم الان من
خلال وجودها في مجلس الامن
يعني البرازيل بلد صديق واعتقد من خلال
حضوركم انتم مشاهداتكم
لاحظتوا كم هذا الشعب ودود وكم هو قريب
لنا احنا كشرقيين
بالنسبه للاعتراف بدوله فلسطين البرازيل
كانت اعترفت بدوله فلسطين
ولحقتها في ذلك دول اخرى في امريكا
اللاتينيه هل هذا الكلام الذي تسمعونه من
البرازيليين يعطيكم امل في ان هذا الزخم
سيظل متواصل في امريكا اللاتينيه بالنسبه
لدعم القضيه الفلسطينيه يعني
الرئيس اولا هذا ما اكده لنا
معالي الوزير وزير الخارجيه
وايضا في زياره الرئيس الاولى
للارجنتين والاوروغواي كان واضح في في
تصريحه في دعم القضيه الفلسطينيه ودعم حق
الدولتين بالوجود واقامه الدوله
الفلسطينيه على حدوث 67 وعاصمتها القدس
لا يوجد عنا ادنى شك بهذا التوجه
البرازيلي وتوجه الحكومه البرازيلي
ليتناغم ايضا مع الدعم الشعبي القضيه
الفلسطينيه دعم المؤسسات والمجتمع المدني
البرازيلي في في غالبيته في غالبيه العظمى
بجزم انه هو لصالح الحق الفلسطيني لصالح
حل عادل لهذا الصراع وفي في الشرق الاوسط
شكرا الكم حياكم الله واهلا وسهلا كان ذلك
السفير الفلسطيني لدى البرازيل ابراهيم
الزبن في لقاء خاصه به برنامج من واشنطن
تحت قبه السفاره الفلسطينيه في العاصمه
البرازيليه
روائع البرازيل كثيره ولكن مشاكلها كثيره
ايضا فاذا كانت العديد من الشرائح في
المجتمع البرازيلي ومن بينها العرب
البرازيليون مثلا اذا كانت قد وجدت ارضا
خصبه للنمو والازدهار فان شرائح اخرى لا
تزال تواجه تحديات كبيره يجد بعضها جذوره
في تاريخ البرازيل
[تصفيق]
هذه رقصه شعبيه برازيليه ترتبط بتاريخ
العبيد عندما استقدموا في الاغلال بين
افريقيا رقصه
قد تبدو حركاتها بهلوانيه ولكنها تحكي قصه
ماساويه تمزج بين الرقص كما لو كان كل
راقص يصارع الاغنام وخصمه في ان واحد
وبينما يجد السود البرازيليون ما يجمعهم
بنظرائهم الامريكيين
فان كلا الطرفين يسمع في معاناه
الفلسطينيين صدا لمعاناته هو في العالم
الجديد
ارى امورا متشابهه في الحالتين اعتقد ان
كلا من الفلسطينيين والسود في البرازيل
يعانون مشقه الحياه في النظامين
فلسطين
كانت تلك كيرينو الاعلاميه البرازيليه
والناشطه في مجال حقوق الانسان
ساعود اليها لاحقا في هذه الحلقه بعد ان
اعرج على قصه السود الامريكيين مع قضيه
فلسطين
ربما افقد ما شئت معاشي ربما اعرض للبيع
ثياب وفراشي ربما اعمل حجارا وعتالا
وكالناس شوارع
لكن لن اساوم والى اخر نبض في عروقي
ساقاوم
تقول دافني ميوزك التي تناوبت مع الدكتور
ادمون غريب على قراءه جزء من قصيده عدو
الشمس للشاعر الفلسطيني سميح القاسم
تقول دافني انها فتنت بالقصيده ووجدت فيها
نموذج لتلاقي قصه السود الامريكيين
والفلسطينيين
نيوز شاعره امريكيه كانت قد عملت في دار
النشر درام اند سبير في العاصمه واشنطن
حتى تعرضها للاغلاق عام 1974
وقد نشرت درام اند سبير قصيده سميح القاسم
ضمن مجموعه من القصائد الفلسطينيه الاخرى
التي ترجمها ادموند غريب مع زميله نصير
عروري في نهايه الستينيات من القرن الماضي
وقد وجدت القصيده مكتوبه بخط اليد مع عدد
من الكتب في زنزانه الامريكي الاسود جورج
جاكسون الذي قتل في سجنه في ظروف مثيره
للجدل في عام
ادمن شكرا على استضافتنا في بيتك اولا
بالنسبه لجورج جاكسون
والشعر الفلسطيني
اين التقاطع تقاطع جورج جاكسون والشعر
الفلسطيني في احد قاده الفهود السول اسمه
جورج جاكسون قتل في السجن
وهو من قاده هذا التنظيم وكتب له كتابان
كتاب
اخر هو
الدم في عينه كشفوا عندما قط بعد قتله
ارسلوا اغراضه لوالدته ومن بينهم 99 كتابا
كانت موجوده في السجن عنده واكتشفت امه
ورقه مكتوب عليها قصيده بخط يده اسمها
يعدو الشمس
اعتقد ان هذه القصيده هي قصيدته هو على
انها اغلى انها جورج
لحوالي اربعه عقود تقريبا كان الاعتقاد
انها لجوكس ولكن في يوم من الايام امه
كانت تنظر في مكتبته وشاهدت الكتاب
قرات ان هذا الكتاب هو قصائد فلسطينيه
مترجمه الى اللغه الانجليزيه وان فيها
قصيده اسمها عدو الشمس هذه القصيده لسميح
القاسم
واخبرت الجميع وعند اذا بدات هذه الروايه
بدا الناس يعلموا بان هذه القصيده ليست
فهو بدا الاهتمام مجددا
بكتاب عدو الشمس لانهم وجدوا بان هناك ما
يربط الفلسطينيين والافارقه الامريكيه
هناك الموضوع الظلم موضوع القهر موضوع
العنصريه موضوع
الرغبه في الحصول على الحقوق والعداله
انما هذه القصيده لسميح القاسم كانت ضمن
مجموعه من القصائد الفلسطينيه التي
ترجمتها انت مع هذه العناصر بالضبط هذا
هذه القصه كانت هي انها
صديقه فلسطينيه
اسمها بشرى كرمان
كانت ايضا صديقه لسميح القاسم وعرفتني
بكتاباتي ومره كنت في الاردن وايضا ذهبت
الى
محاضره عن الشعر الفلسطيني شعر المقاومه
والتجديد في الشعر الفلسطيني فاعجب بها
وكن في ذلك الوقت لازلت في الجامعه فعندما
عدت ترجمت بعض القصائد التي حوالي خمسه
وسته قصائد ونشرتها في اعداد مختلفه من
مجله كنت رئيس تحريرها في الجامعه
وعنده بعد فتره قصيره اتصل بي
الدكتور نصير عروري نصير عروري هو من اصل
فلسطيني ناشط واصبح رئيسا
رابطه العرب الامريكيين الخريجين العرب
الامريكيين وفيما بعد وايضا استاذا ممتازا
في جامعه ماسيدس وقال لي انا اترجم انه هو
يترجم ايضا بعض قصائد الفلسطينيه
ولماذا لا نتعاون مع معا ثم ننشر هناك بعض
الاسماء المرتبطه بمساله نشر هذه المجموعه
التي ترجمتها انت والدكتور عروري بعد هذه
الاسماء تشارلي كوب مثلا
واسم اخر اللي هو دافني نيوز ما رايك ان
تتذكر بعد ما حصل في موضوع نشر هذه
الاشعار من ترجمتك انت دكتور عمرو مع
دافني ميوز
معنا الان تحياتي دافنه ارجو ان تكوني
بخير
انا سعيده برؤيه ادموند والتحدث عن ذلك
الكتاب الرائع واقول انني لو ربحت
اليانصيب لقمت باعاده طباعته يعني انت
فعلا امراه رائعه لانك انت اخبرتيني عن ان
هذا الكتاب وصل سعره الى 900 دولار
واخبرتي قراءك وكتبت مراجعه جميله وقيمه
وتربط العلاقه بين الفلسطينيين وبين
الامريكيين من اصول افريقيا
لقد نشات في بيت قام فيه ابوايا بتنشاتنا
على ان الصراعات متوازيه وان هناك تلاقيا
بين الفلسطينيين والامريكيين من اصول
افريقيه
وقد دفعت بذلك قدما من خلال ما قمت به من
عمل ففي الوقت الذي انضممت فيه الى
العاملين في مكتبه درام وسبير وتم نشر هذا
الكتاب فاجاني محتواه وادهشني واتمنى لو
تمت اعاده طباعته وفي الحقيقه فانني اتصور
ماده دراسيه كامله تدور حول هذا الكتاب
كان رئيس
دار النشر دراما
وقال احدى النقاط المهمه التي يتذكر انه
اعطاها كمقابله لاحدى وسائل الاعلام هنا
في الولايات المتحده قال ان دار النشر لم
يكن الهدف منها هدف تجاري وانه اعتبر ان
كتاب
عدو الشمس
هو عمل كلاسيكي
يحظى باعجاب واسع في المجتمع الفلسطيني
ومجتمع الامريكيين السول ما هي اهميه هذه
الملاحظه ودور كاب لناشر هذا الكتاب
والكتب الاخرى
يعتبر هذا الكتاب مقياسا حقيقيا في تلاقي
الادب الفلسطيني والادب الافريقي الامريكي
في الولايات المتحده والشتات اما مكتبه
دراموس بير فلم تكن مؤسسه تجاريه تسعى الى
الربح بل منتدى سياسيا وثقافيا وبدونها لم
تكن تلك الاعمال الادبيه قد نشرت
النار
انا سعيد جدا انه
صارت هذه الفرصه لهذا الحوار بينك وبين
دافني ميوز عندي لها سؤال اضافي قبل ان
نودعها وسؤالي لك دافني الان هو ما هي
بتصورك انت حدود المقارنه بين قضيه
الفلسطينيين وقضيه الافارقه الامريكيين
بدي اسابيع لاجيب عن هذا السؤال وليس
دقائق
اعتقد ان العنف الذي تعرض له شعبان وتعرضت
له ثقافه كل منهما العنف الجسدي والتاريخي
ومحاولات محو اصواتنا فبعض ما يحدث اليوم
كقتل طائر نيكولز على يد الشرطه هنا
يذكرنا بما هو شبيه له يوميا في فلسطين
واشعر ان من مصادر قوه قصيده عدو الشمس
انها تتجاوز حدود الزمن لتبقى معاصره ان
لها اهميه تاريخيه ولكنها ترتبط بما هو
معاصر ايضا
شكرا جزيلا نراك على خير
عوده اليك
اين ترى انت حدود التشبيه بين قضيه
الفلسطينيين وقضيه الافارقه الامريكيه من
ناحيه يمكن القول بان هناك ربما انفتاح
اكثر في المجتمع الامريكي بحيث ان وصلنا
رئيس
من افارق الامريكيين يصل الى السده
الرئاسه في الولايات المتحده ولكن على
الرغم من ذلك لا تزال هناك الكثير من
المعاناه هناك التعامل الرؤيه المزدوجه
والطريقه التعامل الموضوع التعليم احيانا
المدارس فرق كبير بين المدارس في المدن
ذات الغول المناطق ذات الغالبيه الافراغ
الافريقيه الامريكيه
والبيضاء وان كان هناك مناطق للبيض ايضا
تعاني من نفس المشكله هناك ايضا المعامله
التي تحدثت عن اهداف لموضوع الشرطه نرى
فعلا صحيح ان احيانا الشرطه يقتل بيض ايضا
ولكن وكانت غالبيه وكانت من قتل
الطائره كانوا من الفارق الامريكيين ولكن
هناك مشكله حقيقيه في التعامل مع اولاد
والنسبه بالنسبه للعدد السكان التعامل مع
الافارق الامريكيين خاصه شباب يختلف عن
التعامل مع غالبيه هناك هذا الشعور بالقهر
شعور بالمعاناه شعور بالظلم الذي عبر عن
اشخاص مثل جورج جاكسون عباره عن شخص مثل
ستوكلي كار مايكل الذي اصبح معروف
والذين ايضا ظهروا وصلوا لقناعه لان
تقريبا نفس المشاكل التي هم يعانون منها
يعاني منها الفلسطينيين ما هي الصعاب التي
واجهتها انت والدكتور عروري في نشر هذه
الترجمه لهذه القصائد الفلسطينيه بما فيها
عدو الشمس فعلا وجهنا تحديات كبيره ارسلنا
الكتاب الى 12 دار نشر
فهو سبب الحقيقي لذلك ان الافكار والاراء
المطروحه في الكتاب
والتحدث عن ما يعاني الفلسطينيين كان
السبب الرئيسي وراء عدم الاهتمام بهذا
الكتاب
شكرا جزيلا مره اخرى على استضافتنا في
بيتك شكرا لكم وشكرا لكم على هذا الاهتمام
عوده الان الى البرازيل مع كيلي كيرينو
الاعلاميه والناشطه في مجال حقوق الانسان
مرحبا بك في برنامج من واشنطن بالنسبه
للتحديات التي تواجه الفلسطينيين
والتحديات التي تواجه
السود البرازيليين يعني تحديدا في الحياه
اليوميه ما هي التحديات المشتركه بتصورك
هذه
يعاني السود في البرازيل من صعوبه الحصول
على وظائف يعانون مشقه كبيره وكذلك لا
يحظى الصودو في البرازيل بفرص للسكن
الملائم انما يعيشون فيما يطلق عليه
او المساكن العشوائيه خاصه في المدن
الكبيره كريود جانيرو وساو باولو ومدن
اخرى
الرواتب ايضا ليست مناسبه ولسوء الحظ
يتلقى الموظف اسود البشره في البرازيل
راتبا اقل من نظيره الابيض ولهذا يتاثر
مستوى معيشه السود سلبا وفوق ذلك كله هناك
مشكله عنف الشرطه
ففي كل عشرين الى ثلاثين دقيقه يقتل في
البرازيل شخص اسود على يد الشرطه وهذا
يحدث لان النظام لدينا قمع وهذا ما نطلق
عليه العنصريه وهذه العنصريه تقتل السود
بالنسبه لي لاسرائيليه الاسرائيليون
يقولون انهم يقتلون الفلسطينيين
ويتهمونهم بممارسه الارهاب الفلسطينيون هم
ايضا يتهمون الاسرائيليين بممارسه ارهاب
الدوله هل هناك اي شيء مشابه لهذا في
علاقه الشرطه في البرازيل بالمدنيين خاصه
الشباب
في البرازيل لا يواجه السودو اتهامات
بالارهاب لكن
يتهمون بالتجاره في المخدرات وتهريبها
وغالبا ما توجه اتهامات تتعلق بالمخدرات
الى الشباب السوداء وهكذا يرسلون السود
وخاص الرجال الى السجن بمبررات واتهم
التجاره في المخدرات وفي هذا السياق
يتشابه الوضع في اسرائيل مع وضع السود في
البرازيل حيث يتم ارسال الشباب
الفلسطينيين والسود البرازيليين الى
السجون وتقدم مبررات ولكن لا يتم تقديم
حلول للمشكلات الحقيقيه وفي هذا نرى قمع
الدوله في كل من الحالتين الفلسطينيه
والبرازيليه
كانت تلك كيرينو انتهت الحلقه تحيه لكم من
هذا الموقع الفريد موقع السفاره
الفلسطينيه بهندستها وقفتها اللتين
تستحضران قبه الصخره في مدينه القدس مع
الشكر للسفاره الفلسطينيه في برازيليا على
المساعده التي قدمتها للبرنامج في هذه
الحلقه والشكر موصول كذلك للرئاسه
البرازيليه على كل التسهيلات التي قدمتها
لفريق البرنامج من البرازيل عملاق امريكا
اللاتينيه بموغرافيا واقتصاديا ودبلوماسيا
ودعكم على جناح السلامه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]